for anyone that listens and is like well
I'm never going to go to or I tried
therapy once and it didn't work out for
me is like it's not what that's not one
size fits-all either you know it it is
you if you go to a therapist and you
don't like the way they do therapy like
you should always make a few
appointments like you know a a lot of
therapists will offer like potentially a
free introduction you know session or
change therapist if you don't feel the
vibe just change it change therapist
it's not your fault if it doesn't work
out it's no and if they're a good
therapist they should say like
absolutely I had one guy I left him
years ago I went to him probably a
handful of times and it's like the third
session the guy's like eating a Subway
sandwich while he's talking to me in the
room he's just eating a Subway sandwich
I'm sorry I haven't had lunch are you
okay with that I'm like no do I have a
choice I have a choice you're hungry
what am I going to say no and then it's
awkward for the next hour but you're
just you're picking out on this
sandwich do you have to put so much Mayo
on there it's on your lips